let's do this
so this is a local i heard about this
local news oh was this a florida thing
of course of course it's a florida thing
uh this is a johnny damon he's a retired
baseball player got pulled over
for suspected dui
body cam footage
[Music]
i know where this is
wait i gotta i i gotta forget that
closer i think i know where this is
hey shut your door shut your door shut
your door
okay shut the door what the [ __ ] signal
44.
we're off to a good start get back in
the car
i know where this is
i'm trying to look it up i know where it
is already but you could look it up but
um
this looks like the entrance to the
margaritaville resort
where you could like you know you get
you could buy you could buy homes and
it's also a resort
am i right is that what it is what what
part of what part of floor would that be
in
being orlando close
where well very affluent suburb of
orlando
is this in uh windermere it's windermere
windermere police department are the
ones that are arresting him in this
call of course good call of course they
did
all right turn the car off
like that's he's more drunk than i was
when i got my dui and i was [ __ ]
hammered this dude is
gonzo windermere makes sense too
he's so [ __ ] up everything he's doing
is wrong
he's trying to act cool yeah
officer what's up you're like oh god
he's not doing good this is not a good
start
step back here all right what are you
doing i'm
going home okay stand right here okay
any weapons in the car
no okay keep hand out of your pocket
okay leaning against your car
okay okay what's going on here why is
she getting out
um because oh wow
he is gone this isn't like buzzed
he's plastered well um he apparently
was four times the legal limit
do you know what his breathalyzer was
what was it point
three zero
that is by the way that's you're
you're reaching a moment where it's
starting to that's
endangering your life drinking that's
not oof
we saw you following us yeah
buddy he sounds like me and dutch
whenever he visits and we're catching up
a couple hours in too much booze do your
[ __ ] bear
is here it's just good to see me
we know we don't we don't see shut it
enough
traffic stop you don't get out of the
car in the traffic stop
what traffic stop i think he'll be fine
rice i think he could still talk his way
out of this one
you think he can no not at all he could
he was
the minute he got out of the car and he
said get back in the car and he went
what the [ __ ] man it was over for him do
you see the police lights
yeah yeah it just happened right yeah
it's called a traffic stop
okay it just happened right there he's
great i love this man
he's my favorite but i don't even like
baseball but he's my favorite baseball
player i want one of his rookie cards
sorry the passenger jumped out on me uh
she's back in the car now
kind of the white man out of the vehicle
so i'll explain why i'm soft in a second
before and something about windermere
police that you really have to
understand
windermere police is one of those cities
where there really isn't any crime
it's very affluent i mean most they make
most of their money if you're going like
32 and a 30 or
if you didn't stop long enough it's a
stop sign so they don't really have a
difficult job
they probably have about four cops on
duty at any given time yeah yeah it's
it's not
it's nothing crazy it's like that what's
that uh
like all there's all those little beach
towns too in florida have the same thing
like golden beach
yeah like there's all the gold yeah
there's all these little
like dotted islands that you go oh well
i would assume that's miami pd and
you're like
nope every little 10 mile sliver of land
has their own police department
or something have a backup officer come
so
okay how much
how much we had to drink tonight uh i'm
not a big drinker
i'm gonna guess a lot two beers
i have one or two drinks with dinner yes
okay it's gonna be what it is
oh a little bit just a little bit
oh [ __ ] man yeah all right
so yeah comfort zone for you one well
i've been behind you you've left your
lane multiple times
the cop drunk he's also a little where
he might be
yeah just say hi okay well i've been
behind you you've left your lane
multiple times and you actually struck
the curve at one point on main street
and then the stop sign back there oh
he's in the heart main street he's in
the
heart of windermere which you don't like
i used to avoid driving through there
even when i was sober but i had like
some weed on me and stuff i'd be like i
don't even wanna bother
going through that part of town because
it's one of those or they'll pull you
they'll go
you're a strange car what are you doing
around here
you stopped all the way past the stop
bar the white line on the ground
everyone's asking if this cop
is bubble the love sponge it might be
around you have to stop behind it hey
shut your door
stay in the car or stay in the car stay
there
hey stay there sir sir stay right there
did she just say i'm allowed to get out
i guess i
lady can i say something here and i know
people are gonna be mad at this
and i think you know what i'm about to
say
the same situation it's a couple black
dudes
oh they'd be dead i think it would have
gone this smoothly again look i'd be
again we just you heard us whole take
out the georgia
and they'd be going foreign at which
point they became agitated
the officer felt in danger of his life
yeah
and he unloaded his service weapon and
then went to his car
reloaded his service weapon and then
unloaded it can
go over there um listen to them step
over there okay
um stay in the car okay
all i'm saying is oh this woman
oh my god all i'm i stay in the car
while she gets out
all i'm saying is you know i said like a
year ago during the george floyd stuff
that
you know the police could could really
do well if they shot some of these white
women
right wouldn't it help with their pr a
bit because i think everyone finds white
women
supremely annoying and i feel like it
would be
it would help them it would help their
pr more than hurt them
apparently this gets even worse from
what i'm saying i'm saying stay
in the
she just did the hip lean
in the car oh are you are you going here
by the way can i just say something i've
been in enough cars that have been
pulled over and stuff
uh i've been i've been the driver
and uh i i've been the passenger and
when you are the passenger
you're in you're in the sweet zone it's
very difficult
to become arrested if you're the
passenger it's the easiest gig and
all you got to do is they might they
might come over and ask for your id
too and run it you'd be like yeah here
you go sorry about that and that's
all you have to do is sit in that truck
and have a cigarette and by the time the
cigarette's done
he'll be in jail and then they'll go
okay you're free to go
stand over here hey we are right stand
over here
oh yeah she's the worst part of this
because he's going to jail
yeah he's going to jail but she's like
in a position where all she has to do is
shut up and sit in the truck
and hey lady you're already home they'll
probably just tell you can you somebody
in the house that could bring the car
home
you could walk home oh the cop would
probably even drop her off at the house
right there get back in the car all
right get back
in i'm going to talk get back in the car
all right
don't touch me
this woman man
this just makes me like him now more
he's coming off more likeable and he's
an
absolute disgrace yeah don't touch me
don't [ __ ] touch me don't touch me
and now it's gonna get bad
no hey stop stop fighting one two
actually
hey now she's going to jail because
she's leaving the scene
it's all you had to do was sit in the
passenger seat and go
okay okay oh wait here is she gonna go
talk to the security guard
i've been in the passenger sheet during
a doi stop where the person went to jail
i've had drugs on me but because i
wasn't the
they weren't that's now they were
interested they just wanted to get this
guy
who was drunk and i've had to do the old
take an uber i'll call a cab and go home
thing but like all you got to do they
won't they really won't [ __ ] with you
usually if you're the passenger
well if you're the white guy if you're a
white guy or a white woman and you're a
passenger
um just sit there and go okay here's my
id
whatever
we are we are stuck turn around turn
around
turn around turn around and now the
guy's gonna pay for her ignorance too
this guy's gonna pay for it
we are turn around okay we are
at home right now i don't know what you
are doing
face the car okay
hey secure her right now no bat leo
hey babe battery leo
hey man can you not call me fat leo like
in front of people
like i get that that's like the our
nickname at the [ __ ] you know station
but can you now call me fat leo hey yo
please don't i like that he's even
giving her bad instructions just go home
just go home they have no jurisdiction
here
hey what what are you doing
stop trying to pull away from me i'm not
yeah you are you keep walking away
hey can your
he's now saying blue lives matter blue
lives matter well that's
we're on your side
oh bat leo okay so it's battery law
enforcement officers i thought they were
saying fat leo
fat leo okay no look at me
look at our look at all those plates
guys we are off
by the way he did go to jail can i can i
make everybody
really mad uh she has not been charged
with anything
she's a woman dude look when they talk
about male privilege
nowhere is that less prevalent than in
the justice system i mean there are
thousands of cases there was a case in
tampa in the 90s
where this girl was a teenager and her
older boyfriend
um killed her mom like took a bunch of
lsd killed her mom took her credit cards
went on this [ __ ] crazy spree
um the dude is i think on death row
or he's serving life without parole
she's up for parole in like six years
because but it's like you read the story
she planned it she was her idea to kill
her parents
the dude did the crime but like they all
covered up the body cut it up all this
[ __ ]
women never get punished the same as men
in the justice system or at all really
[Music]
look at our license plate
they have a blue lives matter license
plate clearly you're off the hook then
your life matter like this is crazy
yeah i thought if i bought this eight
dollar decorative license plate holder
that panders to police officers i
thought i could drive around with a
point
zero put a point [ __ ] three zero
blood alcohol content
i thought that'd be all right
okay
how about this how about you got a lego
baseball
silent i was signing baseball glove and
they're like nobody cares about you
kevin keep her out for a second
hey we we are good people
we are good people i'm telling you
all right then you're free to go okay
hey we are
um sinister charlie says that must have
been a fun next morning oh my god dude
going to jail sucks bad enough going to
jail and then weaning off of drugs or
alcohol is the [ __ ] one
waking up waking up hungover is bad
waking up in jail is bad
waking up hungover in jail is [ __ ]
brutal
yeah she was a passenger so she she's so
proud of her cuffs
yeah she's a passenger we
no know was just singing she's a big
jeff tones fan
she was just singing songs asia struck
me i
okay i am all for you
police officers yeah what's your name
boss
john again okay i was just trying to
talk to you she refused my orders to
stay in the vehicle
okay all right and then when i grabbed
her because she was resisting
okay she struck back at me okay
all right she should be charged like
this is ridiculous
she's a tough girl she
fights all the time it's not helping
and you know he's probably right he
might be drunk with this he's right
she'd probably just fight all the time
yeah hey babe
yeah bro i i am like the
cleanest guy ever cops love when they
call you bro
yeah it's their favorite they love that
bro
i'm yeah i'm like i'm like a cleanest
guy
[Music]
hey can we stop it of course we stop at
mcdonald's
on the way to jail please
yeah i am not
what are you doing johnny right yeah
okay
turn around right here all right and
just sit you see this push bar right
here you see this bar just sit down on
it
all right okay all right there you go
just like that
all right
[Applause]
hey bro what's going on i'll explain in
a sec okay
cameras out here do you guys have
cameras out here
yeah but uh you guys are too far back
all right cool
did they live in here
they were so close to home they were so
close to home
i doubt they're gonna have any weapons
buddy all right
once we get one more officer here i'm
gonna explain a little more what's going
on
well thank you hey bro i'm a good
[ __ ]
guy i know okay but
hear that but come on
i don't think that has anything to do
with it yeah
okay it does
that's neither here nor there right now
that's not why i'm stopping you though
[Music]
so this where are you guys coming from
tonight
oh london house
london house let me explain something to
you about london house which is
something that i'm
very very well aware of i've never been
you can't be
i couldn't go oh it's a man not a
country club
so london house if you look it up london
house is a private club but it's not a
country club
it's um it's like a restaurant and a bar
but just to apply not to get in
just to apply to be part of the london
house you have to put five thousand
dollars to fill an application and you
don't get the money back if you don't
get in
so it's fine it's really all the when
all the rich windermere people go to
london house oh
so it's a comedy festival
it's fire fest so that's the
so look you could look up so london
house is like this really
there's only a couple of them in the
world there's one in london of course
there's one here and it's very very
high-end um like some people make the
mistake when you walk by it because it's
in a place where nice restaurants are
when you walk by you look at the bar
like if you walk around a bar this
happened to somebody just walk around on
the outside look at the bar that's a
nice bar
a bouncer will come out and be like you
can't be looking in here you can't be
filming in here this is a private
london house is one of the places where
those first couple weeks where we kind
of were locked down
london house was one of those places
that was allowed to be open because it
was a private club
so it's it's one of those work arounds
this london house is very
very high-end not many people could get
into it it's very expensive to be into
it it's very hoity-toity
taxes and all that stuff so he's uh
we're just having a good time there
so prior to her getting out
and that whole struggle going on okay
my concern is when like when i stopped
you guys
okay you want to see the london house
yeah i've been trying to find pictures
but it's
this is the house okay this is the bar
it's all high-end stuff uh this is the
people that
work there it's it's hard to find inside
pictures because they don't even let you
do that
but yeah this is the this is the london
house
what a stupid gimmick like if i had all
the money in the world there's just some
things i would never participate in
yeah so the london house in orlando is
was in style magazine
located in the heart of delgado estates
on restaurant row orlando's newest
business venture is gaining more than
just an intrigue notoriety for good
reason london houses florida's first
ever high society private club
in itself with its elegance and esteem
is nothing short of a complete uh
and utterly enticing founded by adrian
everett entrepreneur and former ceo of
e-lights e-cigarettes his wife
uh josie everett and ben bechten luxury
real estate agent and investor based in
florida london house is already making
an unforgettable impression orlando
would never before seen lifestyle
experience
members seeking a community of
like-minded individuals now
here's your problem the moment they said
where are you coming from cops ask that
for a reason
cops ask what restaurant you're at for a
reason because
in many places if you over serve
the restaurant can get in trouble for
over
serving somebody which is why
we used to have bottled water at our
club that was branded
it had our club on it and i used to tell
my door girl
that people were allowed to leave with
their bottled waters but to make sure to
tear all the labels off
that was a big rule of mine and noma and
i also got rid of
we used to have a policy of having
matchbooks made with our logos on it and
i stopped that i was like well first of
all we're spending money
on [ __ ] and second of all god forbid
somebody's gonna [ __ ]
wrong way drive on 275 and plow into
some off-duty cop
and they're gonna have the matchbook
from our club in their pocket
nope yeah you don't let people have any
kind of
[ __ ] when they leave your spot so the
london house like oh so orlando's rule
is
all bars and restaurants in in this area
of orlando they have to be closed by two
yeah they have that 2 a.m thing london
house gets to be up until 3 a.m because
it is a
private private club private
establishments
yeah uh and to get in there i mean even
bringing a guest is almost impossible
first off you know we're getting out and
stuff
literally sounds crazy either way
i don't care my wife is crazy i want to
get you home
yeah but you're not going home but we
have just 200 yards too
they're so close well that's that's
usually
where people get popped yeah absolutely
all right i understand so i just had a
couple drinks it's completely
okay if you have some drinks in the
drive but it's okay my concern is you
might be
too impaired to drive so i'm
not that impaired i mean he made it 200
yards away from my house would you be
willing to do
i understand would you be willing to do
some field sobriety exercises to make
sure
i would be uh could i make a prediction
here
he's going to nail this
well he didn't do it no once one more
officer gets here
little i'm great all right
what we're going to do is one more
officer gets here i'll take those cuffs
off
i'll walk through the exercises we'll go
from there okay
um i i i maybe he did do it through it
but i don't have the video of him doing
it [ __ ]
that's all i have from the body that
would be on the field sobriety the field
of variety says will be on the body
camps normally right
johnny let me see if i could find it
because i now at this point
we're in now uh
johnny demon
uh sobriety
test let me see what i come up with here
[Music]
i'm not fine i'm not finding the the
sobriety test i'm just showing
all the videos are this
i guess some of you got i mean i guess
he's a pretty famous baseball player
i don't know who he is i'm sure a lot of
people that have been to baseball know
who he is
some of the best quotes were man it's
being crazy being arrested for nothing
i get it with two blocks from our house
it's [ __ ] but i get it
when other officers in the station ask
the arresting officer for the charges
damon
replied arrested for being sober
great he's the best he played for a long
time no he was yeah he had i mean i'm
not a big baseball guy but
he had like an 18-year career dude he
played for the red sox and the yankees
and i think the rays
and he was all over his mother is ty
and his father is of croatian and irish
descent
oh there you have it
it's definitely uh i just i'm really
annoyed that this woman got no charges
from this
yep it always works out that way yeah
a point three uh blood alcohol content
is that's extremely dangerous to have
and apparently it was when they drew
blood
and it was like two hours after that oh
yeah then that's pretty big
he was way up there man and that's like
look i like to drink and everything but
there's
there's levels of it where you go jesus
dude like that's
bad you could that you could [ __ ] die
from that
forget about driving a car and crashing
it you could literally
just die from that much